[Music]
welcome to games you should know by
heart
brought to you by Grandmaster been
finding now as you know today there was
a gameplay to the grand chest tour it's
your move between somebody and somebody
else Kramnik and Aronian your two
favorite players and Aronian got a lot
of pass pawns and so two Kramnik but
Aronian one and i was talking to my son
about this game and that reminded us of
the game would see McDonald on the
Bourdonnais and their match went for
several weeks so there was several
matches and Laborde was better and I
read the Wikipedia article about those
two players of their match you got to
read that it's pretty funny yeah those
are some funny guys and then it turned
out laborda knee had to leave because
creditors were looking for him in paris
so you had to get back okay they played
in London McDonald was from Ireland I
guess and Laborde name was from France
and so forth and this is a very famous
game which you need to learn by heart
are you two at home okay and because
we're off imitated this game and he said
very suspicious then because far I went
to my chess game he said this game's
great so he change his mind
yeah okay so this is Sicilian and in
this position I've told all my students
and all my relatives don't play this
move Arjun that's the usual answer I
mean in this position whoo yeah yeah II
five yeah yeah and and II five is
reasonable but don't do that
okay now even Kasparov said every
Russian schoolboy would play what move
here whoo 95 yeah that's his northern
move and there were notes to this game
by thing Staunton or somebody even older
and he's like we treat the night
somewhere boo okay white plays the worst
move even worse than you guys would play
although you guys would all play it
what's that yeah now you're talking
yeah it's 1834 give him a break
yeah yeah but 1834 so I was born in 1835
they didn't know that all right so
taking either ways fine PC and this is
c4 is also not what I would play I think
black played perfect this game White's
not not so perfect Bishop g5 is
ridiculous all right wife's I almost
lost here Queen e2 is terrible
everyone's terrible the sheriff's [ __ ]
is terrible yeah okay but the famous
game okay
so black has the two bishops in the
center because white played so well
alright castles eight fives really good
move for 1834 because we got a four
comment and we got this your base Nick's
coming that's pretty good for 1834 give
a guy that's pretty guys now I read
about these players that of 1834 says
play all lies that leborgne a would move
very quickly in a Preston style he would
think a few seconds to move they said
McDonald occasion would take an hour to
on a move ok very suspicious their games
took several hours then they said
McDonald was exhausted and would go to
bed immediately laborda name would stay
all night at the chess club playing
chess with everybody
they said often playing 30 or 40 games
after this game pledges with everybody
and he'd be up drinking and so forth the
other guy would be dead asleep but yeah
well he's French what do you want okay
so a 5c takes d5 winning upon now this
should a six I can play Bishop c4 yeah
now I'm against this I don't like
trading the e pawn for the C pawn so I'm
furious
okay now that's a black you'll be really
good for black later it's good for this
game right V one with subtle threats no
very subtle D 4 C 4 which is yeah
terrible yeah move I had a game one in
1995 it was 95 and I even though the
opponent and where the tournament was
and I can show you the game and
two-thirds and in a similar position
my opponent played c4 law
he should have like c4 to c3 later I've
shown that game but you guys forgot you
really forgot at home yeah you know who
I am
okay you think I'm air closing terribly
so see for that kid do that
[ __ ] glad you got a like put pressure on
this pawn or block it or something okay
c4 is terrible 86 bishop c2 and it was
1834 so blackout mated no all right it
should be 792 Rick you want look it
everything black does is great Bishop d8
stray because it retreats yeah and
what's what's that that's right and
guess what and what and what splash next
to move good to be yeah
then black Sue and pretty well so black
has the center in to bishops some five
Queen c6 all never play I don't know
what he played but I'll be playing
absolutely and I look good I had no idea
what he played I was thinking goes play
a freezing it get made it's our playoff
three alright this should be seven
taking a pawn white says no you can't
have that pawn and f5 as suggested by me
yeah
now high-level games today you don't see
positions like this because white sort
of said here's the center here's two
bishops you know they don't do that now
basically because of games like this
they're like man ain't no good
stop giving all that stuff away alright
Queen C for track because it was my
chest camp and they like to check Bishop
a for Queen age six Bishop take CA f/64
confusing the audience okay so why sup
an exchange but black has all these
passed pawns f3 is hanging the bishop is
hanging two bishops
and his name is closer than his
opponents that I even is whole name he
has a lot more yeah actually seems
taillight well he's been his name for
boarding a but they could put the you
know de neige so got to be a good joke
in there somewhere
alright so c6 he takes f3 can
using the audience oh wait I meant me
what's going on here I need an adult I
guess if he takes like a check check
check check mate that's pretty good so
he didn't do that so my analysis in my
head was Queen here check and then check
and then I prefer black I don't know if
rookie twos right but it's good enough
yeah and then you keep checking repeat
and here yeah and then here and then you
hate yeah I mean alright right Arjun
that's theory yeah that's looking
McDonald Laborde name alright so after
ef3 but light play Trixie to which I
guess stops all that nonsense check King
h1 Bishop c8 always retreat right now
I don't like whites anything and I like
this but I like this this this this I
like this this Kings pre-safe bishops
hanging okay
700 passed pawns 10 okay this 57 f2
pretty strong look f1 d3 oh here comes
the Shaq attack 63 Bishop takes pawn
takes e4 it's funny because of the game
today between cranek and Aronian Kramnik
actually cleaned his fun and then
Aronian had 700 passed pawns
so truth hurts it's very similar and
erroneous a key exchange so very similar
except even a rhodius position wasn't
this good or was it it's pretty good
yeah it was pretty good
Queen CA and black resigned on the way
black won this game that's a pretty cool
game you've memorized it so far right
it's the games you should learn by heart
you with some crazy comment who that's
your crazy comment that wasn't very
crazy you got to work on that after
Queen e1 if black plays Queen f8 what
should you always play right I don't
know what he played
there should be a that stuff's
everything now you got nothing right
yeah Queenie one rixy one resigns
publicly black resigns white resigns but
all right Queen c4 Queenie one
recommended by origin work c1
recommended by me d2 and the truth hurts
this is good because when they play the
next game of the match set up for the
next game
yeah those funds are getting close to
where they're supposed to be and white
squad on g7 is there so that's good too
all right Queen c5 I don't see the
threat that's out onto the threat and
you're supposed to say the threat for
white all right so he's threatening mate
that's usually a good defense to your
ponent queening rook g8 safe man rogue
GA Bishop g8 white doesn't have a lot of
counter play he stopped the maid he
stopped the pawn from cleaning correct
and bughouse White's doing well ah
nakamura style nobody come on my best
road of the day all right
rugby one draw agreed stalemate
exactly III the truth hurts so this is a
very famous game I don't play over the
game too often I just like the end which
is we're getting close to the end yeah
now generally at the very top level of
chess when these kinds of things are
about to happen
for example the kavaja lanch game
between I've lecture on that came come
on come on come on our lecture on the
game I even said one of the guys names
and ok goof alcoholic student Olympiad I
don't know 62 am i right on the Internet
am i come on you let you put the
description of it was a 62 yeah you
don't know now what's funny about that
is Kaval ik is a u.s. grandmaster but he
wasn't then he played for country that
no longer exists yeah it's like a
Slovakia did man oh yeah highest rated
players always write weird yeah
now wow it is it
ah Czechoslovakia what's it now yeah and
yeah there you go yeah
getting pretty smart no wonder I call on
you a lot okay
Queen c3 and no I don't like it
alright now the very famous ending which
you all know you
yeah only took something daddy one here
yeah and now finally the truth hurts
yeah what would have he played you two
that's funnier that's funnier does that
win does that does that winners that
lose e to look on D takes II won now did
you take the other point I play Queen
takes yeah but I think you're still
winning I think you're still winning
this you're up a piece that's
complicated a fast one you made it
really complicated this was not
complicated yeah
also you have to do this because it's
really cool yeah so Roni was trying to
do this he couldn't quite do a book
close alright so when I was a kid I knew
that position but I never looked at the
game because it was too complicated
yeah and somehow the guy with the black
pieces he won that match they consider
it six or seven matches because they
played over weeks and then McDonald won
one of them five games before but
Laborde won in a lot of games the final
score was like plus twenty or something
for the board game yeah they were
considered the two best players
yeah very unofficial yeah don't you guys
have unofficial stuff here like Ben
Simon you play two game matches those
are unofficial right unofficial yeah
yeah they played forever yeah they
didn't play with a clock for obvious
reasons Arjun
there you go no chess clocks then yeah
that's good it's a good excuse yeah they
did have a digital clock but lately I
don't use that right no okay now the
next game is by my favorite player Ben
Simon I mean not Ben Simon
no okay yeah Paul Morphy I can't make
that joke so we'll continue that's right
now on the Internet it says his opponent
trooper that wasn't his name they just
made up a name like doofus that's like
yeah like his Lincoln wasn't trooper and
one guy rub it's not true for he was
just chauffer there's no trooper I
thought that was fun here yeah they had
better jokes than I do
I don't know yeah but everybody agrees
his name wasn't true for that it doesn't
a joke
I mean it doesn't have like Rufus to the
middle somewhere okay so this is a
famous game you all know the endgame but
you don't know the rest of the game
you know the Angela guy I've seen that
so actually they played a ton of theory
which in 1859 is pretty impressive
in fact the executive director of said
chess club this one plays this with
white like every game this variation and
you could play Queen a5 or Queen h5 but
the way black played is the way they
play now so yeah this is considered like
all best moves for everybody that's why
they'll place with white because this
gives nothing and here both sides
started playing badly because that was
the style at the time yeah they didn't
play well then they must have come to
this club and stood outside and it's
tough to watch those games yeah the
game's improved when it started raining
so they stopped playing there were fewer
mistakes okay so in this position raise
your hand or yacht the answer either way
what should black do there's only one
move good players play here exactly
castles I think theory says black is
slightly better but this was 1859 they
didn't shirk away from the
responsibilities right Arjun yeah so
black played a bad move this should be
four and now a lot of them was were bad
but more fees bad moves led to
in checkmate sounds cool and blacks bad
moves led to a brilliant checkmate which
you guys are cleaner so Knight takes c6
is very strong but he played more few
style Rick takes c6 right and then what
an Emer will say right that was even
born yet didn't care all right and now
according to all engines especially the
one I used black has one move that
equalizes it ain't the move on plan I
play it now but I'm going to even think
of it during the game man engines are
tough
yeah castles correct but you didn't tell
me which way only what is legal
dude essay to test dude ah you're
funnier than me you're not even trying
yeah only one ways legal alright are you
in my camp okay you sure cause the
acting like it I know yeah which one
over there yeah did you be hearing the
same ol
good excuse yeah yeah I heard Ben Luger
him you know why talk about the Benjamin
really that's even better
yeah at one point there were five Ben's
in this building that was that was a
good day yeah I remember that day yeah
okay so what is other than the illegal
moves
suggested by Arjun what is the best move
ah he has to put up with Queen f7 was
played but not good what the highest
rated player always right and also
highest rated next to you yeah King D
sevens equal according to the engine
very suspicious the computer said so
make that joke and not get in trouble
hold on let me think about it you'll
just edit it out that's a Rhys Ashley
joke has to do with the engine thing
that's right
okay alright so it was a smooth move
smooth and nobody got that
people here either all right so Queen f7
that seems reasonable
BAM okay and they move just clean again
make sense and now more if he played
Queenie to which the computer doesn't
like and the reason doesn't like it is
funny so black played Bishop d6 what's
the reason the computer doesn't like
cleaning - because blacks should play
again King g7 the computer says it's
okay
and my favorite variation it says after
King g7 the reason Queen e2 is not best
is that after here King CA equal yeah
exactly
yeah I'm like woah yeah so you can see
how more fees opponents didn't defend
well because nobody would yeah yeah crop
probably yeah okay so his opponent
played Bishop g6 which is not good and
here more if she should play like morphe
who would have thunk it like dish of d2
rook e1 etc but luckily he didn't yeah
he played crazier which is good for us
yeah
King g7 which is is that horrible yeah
it is bad but more people is bad later
so it's good for everybody
yeah well just by King d7 so what's the
play it when it's good now you play it
when it's wrong alright now more if he
made a bad move which is good for us
because it worked out really well right
Arjen okay played Knight f7 check that's
what you would have played you know why
you would have played it you don't see
Queen takes Knight so you like may it oh
wait that's my camp I'm confusing
classes sorry I thought I taught contra
all day then how many kids in my camp
would stay made more than all of them
110 percent that's what they give okay
so 96 check is just really good for
white but that's more fun you guys know
if lack did
why you wouldn't take it what'd you do
was I that's your other option all right
but it he's not winning anymore
so you should take it all right and then
he played the obvious move BAM yeah and
then in this position black went too far
this position according to the engine is
equal yes yeah it's a chess game yeah
okay so he played Kings see a double
question mark King eh is the equalizing
move very suspicious but you know it's
funny because gave you seven might be
okay but I doubt it it's funny because
people make fun of Murphy's opponents
they were terrible but the moves that
are correct like nobody would play like
what do you want from them right
what would Adam Lambert say anybody
Arjun now the correct answer was who's
Adam Lambert that was the correct answer
yeah you messed that one up
yeah also who's Tiger Woods I would have
accepted that I would have accepted that
yeah you know who said that Thalia she
said who's that I tried to explain she's
like nope nothing
yeah I tried to help run it over there
with a golf club but it didn't nothing
happened
yeah then I hit her again and she was
fine even number of times and you're
fine right Arjun whoo-hoo yeah that's
Chrissy yep yeah you can yeah what you
know I've already made fun of you
several times today we break okay so
after a king e8 and/or king d7 the game
goes on nothing will be played also
Queen takes Knight that very good okay
so you play King c8 and this position
you all know that was funny because
they're like what you know what they
were thinking here doo-doo-doo-doo okay
yeah I and then white one you argue no
the way white ones we can skip yeah all
right so 9s a check was incorrect
even though Knight shx fine your your
answer is just as good as the game very
good yeah I like your answer better
it shows more indolence or insolence one
of them whichever one is funnier right
okay 95 check now most of you would go
here and then always repeat I mean don't
repeat yeah that's what I meant
and now the problem with blacks position
is he can only legally Castle one way
that's the problem
otherwise the alright alright so he
played the obvious yeah and you all know
the rest yeah and then 95 draw I play 95
right and then I then I play the right
move
I play 95 first torture moan oh yeah
now notice it's double check and if
you're not sure then double check good
okay exactly
so King DA allows mated one then that
wouldn't be fun for anybody and pawn
takes is illegal although recommended by
the campers so King b8 was played now I
would definitely play 97 always repeat
yeah any play clean see yeah yeah and
black didn't see the rook that was here
and it was actually Isaac's Ron so he
resigned in Toronto mate or vice versa
which ever is funnier yeah what happened
he made him without the guy resigned
yeah that was funny yeah okay and then
black didn't resign like my opponents
would I can't believe I'm meeting one of
my opponents resign come on yeah yeah no
don't do that that's that's unfair when
I play Ray Robson he had eight one I
would have made me so let's I never did
in his life that's because he's not a
good player okay then
ninety-seven mate BAM and then would
have more if he do work he cried he did
what took a bow what am i what you don't
know what what did he do
come on Ben Stein what did he do
horrible alright so sending your
interest at home to win a prize one free
your membership at the up the correct
answer obviously is drop the mic yeah
might be seven mate you guys do that a
lot in your games sack all your pieces
were made that's all you ever do yeah
and then they were like ruthless doofus
a shrew fur and then that's what we
played yeah very suspicious but not too
suspicious so those are games you should
memorize or learn by heart or whatever's
funnier
right Arjun I'm not here next week it'll
be Josh tree del Bam and you thought he
wasn't coming but he was joshing yeah
now he he put he put on Facebook and/or
Twitter that he's flying here right now
you with some crazy comment that's right
he was like more fees no good right so
Josh free value like no good Bam's what
happened last time we played actually
don't know probably he won I think he
beat me more than I beaten him alright
see you guys in a few months out
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]